spacex landet rakete auf dem atlantik am
samstag hatten viele von euch in den
kommentaren nach einem video zu dem
sensationellen spacex erfolg gefragt
hier ist es unser video zur
spektakulären falken einladung feld
hinein rakete sicher auf einem träger im
atlantik gelandet am freitag um 22 43
unserer zeit startete das private
raumfahrtunternehmen spacex eine falcon
9 rakete vom us weltraumbahnhof cape
canaveral im us bundesstaat florida
nur zwei minuten nach ihrer abtrennung
vom rest der rakete gelang es die erste
raketenstufe sicher landen zu lassen
gegen 22.50 steuerte der untere teil der
zweistufigen falken 1 rakete die im
atlantik schwimmenden lande basis an
kurz darauf setzte sie sanft auf zitat
die erste stufe ist gelandet und
natürlich sind wir begeistert twitterte
ihnen maske dem leben spacex auch der
elektroautohersteller tesla gehört auch
der us amerikanische präsident barack
obama war begeistert und schrieb auf
twitter com
spacex online-magazins because of
innovators like you and laser web
america continues to lead in space
exploration
außerdem wurde auch einen dragon
raumkapsel zur international space
station iss auf den weg gebracht gegen
mittag dockte die 37 meter im
durchmesser große kapsel an der
raumstation an das was spacex am freitag
gelungen ist ein riesiger fortschritt in
der weltraumfahrt hinter dem erfolg
steckt aber auch jede menge geld und der
ein oder andere misserfolg diesen januar
gelang espace ex ihre falcon 9 rakete
sicher auf dem festland zu landen
mit den worten welcome back babys ihnen
mas die rakete zurück auf der erde
willkommen so reibungslos wie beim start
und der landung im januar so reibungslos
lief ist ein jahr zuvor nicht dabei im
januar 2015 kam es zu einem totalverlust
einer rakete des privat
raumfahrtunternehmens damals flog die
falken 1 rakete die landeplattform zu
schräg und viel zu schnell an die folge
der 35 meter lange untere teil der
rakete kollidierte mit der plattform und
landete anschließend im wasser grund für
die fehlgeschlagenen landung war laut
spacex das dem lande system der rakete
kurz vor der landung
die hydraulische flüssigkeit aus gingen
daraufhin verlor die rakete die balance
trotzdem wurde der versuch damals als
erfolg gewertet im voraus rechnete das
unternehmen mit gerade einmal einer
50-prozentigen erfolgschancen und das
bei optimalen bedingungen die plattform
die so groß ist wie ein fußballfeld
wurde bei dem unfall übrigens nur leicht
beschädigt und konnte danach weiter
genutzt werden anders als bei
herkömmlichen akten system möchtest
basic seine raketen mehrfach verwenden
können anstatt sie nach dem staat
einfach ins meer fallen zu lassen
grund dafür sind natürlich die kosten
die herstellungskosten für eine falcon 9
rakete zb belaufen sich auf insgesamt
knapp 47 millionen euro
der treibstoff für die rakete ist
dagegen relativ günstig gerade einmal
175000 euro kostet der ihnen maaß
gründer von spacex vergleicht einen
raketenstart mit einer brandneuen boeing
nach einem flug verschrottet die
wiederverwendung von raketen könnte eine
neue ära der raumfahrt einläuten
in der flüge ins all um einiges billiger
werden bzw
ja jetzt eigentlich schon sind erst am
samstag berichteten wir in den krieg zum
top five - von dem erfolg des ebenso
privaten raumfahrtunternehmens blue
origin die im jahr 2018 den
weltraumtourismus möglich machen wollen
arbeiten experten weiter auf hochtouren
könnte das tatsächlich bald keine
fiktion sondern realität sein
ich hoffe dass wir mit diesem video die
wünsche nach einem bericht über spacex
erfüllen kommt nicht freue mich dann
über einen daumen nach oben und
natürlich über ein abo dass ihr da lass'
es kostet ja nicht so wie wir heute eure
kommentare auf die kommentare
eingegangen sind möchte ich das auch
gerne demnächst und zwar das format
fraxinea geht in eine neue runde und als
niemand geringeres als ihr gefragt
stellt mir eure fragen unter diesem
video oder auf twitter oder facebook mit
dem hashtag frags ea und einige der
fragen könnten dann schon bald von mir
beantwortet werden ich freue mich auf
zahlreiche fragen und bis dann bleibt
dran